okay we've been talking about Trump tax
reform are they tax cuts all of the
trumpets who are tweeting because
they're angry that their tax refunds
went down and the fact that some of them
are paying more taxes but that many
others don't realize that just because
you get a smaller refund doesn't
necessarily mean that you're actually
paying more tax that got us to a
conversation on Trump's favorite fox
news show Fox and Friends yesterday were
they are just running PR interference
for Donald Trump at this point and this
topic came up on Fox and Friends about
all sorts of tax payers but Trump is
included who have been complaining that
they they're tax refunds are tiny or
they owe money this time as a result of
Donald Trump's tax reform plan and what
they did was of course the egalitarian
populist thing which was to blame the
taxpayers for being too stupid to not
adjust their withholdings at their job
to account for the new tax rates now
this is completely disingenuous I'm
gonna play the clip for you in a second
this is totally disingenuous because the
when the new tax plan rolled out it
wasn't simply left up to employees and
employers to come up with new
withholdings brackets withholdings
tables the Trump administration
published new withholding tables our
payroll company for example if the david
pakman show called me and said hey we
are putting in place than you
withholding tables next pay run do you
want to change them and I said no just
whatever the standard is we want to do
the standard Democrats warned when this
happened be careful because the Trump
administration is putting out new
withholding tables that will get people
more money on a paycheck-to-paycheck
basis they're going to think that this
is their tax cut but in reality it's
going to affect their refund at the end
of the year be careful about that $40
boost to your paycheck because that
might end up being $1,000 you lose from
your refund at the end of the year
didn't matter
now we get to Fox and Friends yesterday
telling Americans it's their fault and
laughing about it what taxpayers are
complaining as the average tax refund
drops an average eight percent from last
year but are you actually making less
money here to break it all down for you
and what it means for your wallet
Charles Payne host of making money with
Charles Rane on the Fox Business Network
so Charles you know people look forward
to their tax refund getting back the
money that they overpaid to the federal
government exactly you know here's the
thing is for the most part the IRS is
telling everyone that they just simply
did not make the proper adjustments on
them with Holdings at the beginning of
the year so they've been making all of
this mistake well it's not necessary a
different state it's the your employer
or you IRS actually put a lot of memos
out they even made it pretty easy to go
on their website and figure it out this
is at the beginning of last year of
course most people didn't do that said
while people weren't obviously seeing
fatter paychecks they were still
counting on that refund that they always
got which is interesting because you
kind of hinted at it that we would allow
you know the IRS to have like a two
thousand dollar loan our money right
hold on yeah because we overpay so
people probably should consider making
these adjustments anyway unless you want
to give the IRS two or three grand of
your money to hold for a year maybe they
can make the answers on it you won't but
the entire sort of condescending
attitude is just toxic yeah how you know
anybody could have just gone to the IRS
website and then looked at memos about
withholding tables and tax rates and
then contacted HR at their employer and
made the change how did not everybody do
that what are these people stupid so
first of all it's not Americans job to
assume that when a new tax plan rolls
out there are also withholding changes
that are meant to be deceptive for
political reasons okay maybe we should
be more skeptical with Trump we probably
should have been more skeptical that
wait a second
maybe the withholding changes are meant
to make me think I've just gotten a tax
cut and in reality this is just money
coming out of my refund but the truth
about the program of tax cuts or tax
change is that the bottom 20% of earners
in the
tree-like the bottom quintile as we call
it they're on average paying $60 less in
taxes per year actual tax due okay not
withholdings versus refund the bottom
quintile is saving $60 a year on average
some people are paying a little more
some people are saving more $60 as the
average the next 20% the sort of fourth
quintile down from the top is getting an
average cut of 380 dollars some people
are paying a little more some people are
paying a little less but the average cut
is 380 dollars the top point one percent
is saving an average of a hundred and
ninety thousand dollars on their taxes
as a result of Donald Trump's tax plan
so what I always go back to Pat is that
yes it's important to understand the
difference between a refund and tax due
just because you get a smaller refund it
doesn't tell you for sure if you
actually paid a higher or lower
effective tax rate but what we are all
forgetting about when we see segments
like this and segments about people who
are living paycheck to paycheck as so
many are is that whether you pay $60
more or $60 less or 380 more or 380 less
which makes a difference but it's not a
huge difference in lifestyle there are
people who have permanent tax cuts the
likes of which are saving them hundreds
of thousands of dollars per year that's
not what the people who put this plan in
place want anybody talking about yeah
and that's why this Trump tax plan had a
approval rating of about 30 to 40
percent which is surprising given that
you would think intuitively that
Americans would want a tax cut that they
would be in support of it I think that
they've now realized that this was
really just a tax cut for the top one
percent the top 0.1% and they got scraps
they got peanuts yep and we will see if
it has any impact when it comes to
voting we may not there is such
cognitive dissonance and continued
ignorant and you know I mean think about
all of the issues here that are
confusing to people number one this
confusion I mentioned between tax a tax
paid and your refund if you make 50
grand a year and you pay 10 grand in
taxes that's a 20 percent tax rate if
you have 12,000 withheld during the year
and get a $2,000
or have 9,000 withheld during the year
and cut a check for $1,000 either way
you paid 10,000 in tax on 50,000 in
earnings a lot of people don't get that
that's confusion number one number two a
lot of people aren't understanding of
the salt limit the state and local taxes
limit which is now $10,000 a year if you
are in a situation where you pay $5,000
in real estate taxes and $7,000 in state
income taxes that's $12,000 under the
new tax law only 10,000 of those 12,000
are deductible so if you're in a higher
tax state or a state with higher
property values you are going to pay
more as a result of the limit on the
salt deduction and these are just a
couple of examples the real question is
how do we break through to give people
the full story about what is actually
happening with their tax rate tax rate
their effective tax rate when you have
the Trump administration running total
disinformation propaganda campaigns and
messing with withholdings to make it
seem like people are getting extra money
back and you have Fox News and others
sort of supporting that propaganda
disinformation campaign for the Trump
administration it is really difficult to
just explain these simple things and it
may lead to what we've been predicting
for a long time despite Trump policy
being bad for most of his supporters
they will vote for him again in 2020 and
that's why we need to vote and we need
to play the turnout game convincing the
trumpet's to change their vote because
Trump lied about their tax cut is simply
not going to work let's take a quick
break I posted a behind-the-scenes
picture to my Instagram today at David
Pakman check that out we will take a
break and be back after this one of
today's sponsors Prez aback is offering
you some free stuff that I want to tell
you about spresso box is based in New
York City they help keep guys wardrobes
fresh without breaking the bank because
when you become a member of spresso box
each month you'll get a new box sent to
your door
filled with five or six
stylish hand-picked accessories and
pieces of clothing for men it includes
high-end socks neckties really nice
sunglasses wallets watches bracelets
high-quality pens and hair combs it's
really classy stuff that makes it easy
to put a little more pop into your
wardrobe without having to spend a ton
of money a subscription is just 25 bucks
a month but your new box every single
month is guaranteed to have items with a
combined value of over $100 a couple of
the things I got are a really nice money
clip a pocket square and some great
socks go check out the different things
that they put in their monthly boxes
they have a lot of really nice-looking
stuff everyone in our audience can get
one month totally free when you click
the link underneath this video and use
the promo code Pakman that's PA que ma N